in an era where Digital Data flows like
the world's V oceans encryption stands
as the lighthouse guiding and protecting
every bite from the stormy seas of cyber
threats at the core of this
cryptographic Safeguard lies the block
Cipher a fortress of algorithms turning
readable data into impenetrable Cotes
yet the true Mastery of data protection
Comes Alive through the Strategic
manuvers known as the mod of operation
with global internet traffic now a
torrent of over 150,000 GB every minute
the art of securing this data is more
critical than ever these modes from the
straightforward electronic Cod book ECB
to the intricate cyber block chaining
CBC and the agile counter CTR mode are
the unsung heroes in the shadows each
playing a pivotal role in the encryption
Saga this video is your gateway into the
captivating Universe of block Cipher
modes of oper operation here we explore
the ingenious designs that Safeguard our
digital conversations transactions and
secrets against the backdrop of a cyers
space filled with lurking adversaries di
to a story not just of algorithms and
Cotes but of the silent Guardians that
ensure the security of a digital world
block by block welcome to the thrilling
invisible Battle of encryption where
every bit and bite has its Shield but
before commencing just a quick info for
you if you are an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with easy Council should
be a right choice this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's degree with a 50% of
average and no prior programming
experience is needed and one plus year
of work experience is preferred for more
details you can use the link mentioned
in the description box and make comment
and if these are the types of videos you
would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press on the
Bell icon to never miss on future
content so stay tuned with us until the
end of this video and don't forget to
register your opinion in the comment
section below so let's start with
understanding encryption so encryption
is the process of converting
understandable data that is print text
into a coded form that is cipher text
that hides the original information's
meaning so the purpose of the encryption
is to protect data previous
ensuring that only authorized parties
can access the original information
using a specific key for decryption and
now we'll see the application for
encryption so it is widely used to
secure data across various platforms
including online transactions
confidential Communications and personal
data storage now moving to the role of
blog ciphers in digital security so blog
ciphers are algorithms that encrypt data
in fix size chunks or blocks each block
of PL text is encrypted separately
turning it into an encrypted block of
cyper text and now we'll see two more
forms of it that is fixed block size so
the size of each blocks is predetermined
commonly 64 or 128 bits which means the
algorithm works by taking precisely the
amount of data at a time for encryption
and then comes the key usage so single
secret key is utilized across the
encryption process transforming plain
text blocks into Cipher text blocks
the same key when correctly applied is
also used to decrypt the cipher text
back into readable plane text so now
we'll see the import of understanding
blog ciphers so the number one point is
foundation of digital security so
learning about blog ciphers is crucial
as they form the backbone of many
encryption systems protecting digital
information today and then we have
versatility through modes of operation
so different operational modes enhance
block ciphers flexibility allowing them
to be tailored to specifically security
requirements and scenarios and then we
have the widespread use from securing
online transactions to encrypting
personal and sensitive information block
ciphers are integral to Modern cyber
security efforts and now we'll compare
blog and Stream ciphers So block ciphers
so the number one point for the block
ciphers would be the fixed size
encryption that encrypts data in blocks
making it ideal for situations where the
total amount of data is known in advance
or can be evenly divided and then we
have the security features so it is
capable of enhancing security through
modes of operation that can for example
help in detecting alterations in the
encrypted data and we talk about the use
case it is predominantly used for
encrypting data at rest such as files on
a disk or data stored in a database and
then we have the Stream ciphers So
stream ciphers have continuous
encryption it encrypts data 1 bit or
bite at a time fitting scenario with the
data flows continuously and the total
volume may not be known beforehand and
if we talk about its efficiency so it's
efficient in real time often faster and
more suitable for encrypting large
volumes of data or streaming content in
real time and now coming to its use case
so it is commonly used for live data
transmission such as streaming audio or
video or realtime communication
applications and now we have importance
of modes of operation in blog ciphers so
now we'll understand modes of operation
so modes of operations are methods that
Define how blocks of plain text are
processed by a Blog Cipher algorithm so
they determine how encryption and
decryption are carried out adding layers
of complexity and security beyond the
basic encryption process and now we'll
see the necessity of different modes the
number one is variety of data types
different types of data example
streaming data static files require
different typ encryption approaches for
optimal security and efficiency and then
we have security enhancements some modes
offer increased security by introducing
Randomness and mitigating patterns in
encrypted data which can prevent
attackers from guessing the content and
then we have functional requirements so
different applications may require
specific features from the encryption
process such as error propagation data
inquiry checks or simultaneous
encryption and authentication so now
let's understand the common modes of
operation so blog ciphers are crucial
for anyone starting in cryptography each
mode has unique characteristics
advantages and disadvantages so we'll
start with the number one that is ECB
electronic code book so let's start with
its procedure so it encrypts each block
of plain text independently using the
same key and it is the simplest form of
encryption and now if we talk about its
advantages it is easy to implement and
the encryption of blocks can be done in
parallel speeding up processing and
about the disadvantages it is identical
plain text blocks resting identical
Cipher text blocks making it vulnerable
to pattern analysis and not secure for
data with patterns now moving to the
next that is CBC Cipher block chaining
so before encryption each block of plain
text is exor with the previous Cipher
text block the first block is exort with
an initialization Vector that is called
IV and it requires IV for the first
block and now if we come to its
advantages so the patterns in the plain
text are well marked and they are more
secure against pattern attacks compared
to ECB and now coming to disadvantages
so encryption cannot be paralyzed due to
the dependency on the previous block
cyer text and the error propagation so
error propagation here refers to an
error in one block that affects the
decryption of the current and subsequent
blocks now moving to the next that is
CFB Cipher feedback so it turns block
Cipher into a stream Cipher by
encrypting segments of a block at a time
and the previous Cipher text segment is
encrypted and then exor with the plain
text segment to proceed the next Cipher
text segment and now talking about its
advantages it is suitable for encrypting
data streams or varing sizes and errors
do not propagate beyond the next blow
now coming to disadvantages it is
slightly more complex to imp ment and
may have lower efficiency due to the
sequential nature of processing now
coming to the next that is ofb output
feedback so similar to CFB but the
output of the encryption is fed back
into the block Cipher for the next cycle
not the cipher text and it is
essentially turns a block Cipher into a
stream Cipher this is for the output
feedback now talking about its
advantages so error in Cipher text does
not propagate to plain text text in O
and it can regenerate key stream and
talking about its disadvantages it must
maintain synchronization between sender
and receiver and it is less commonly
used due to complexities in
synchronization so the last we have is C
counter so it encrypts a counter value
that opens starting with an IV and
incrementing by one for each block and
exort with this file is the plain text
to produce Cipher text and each block is
independent of Furs allowing parallel
processing and now talking about its
advantages it allows parallel encryption
and decryption offering high efficiency
and no error propagation and errors in a
cipher text blocks affects only that
block only and then we have
disadvantages and the disadvantages of
CTR is it must ensure the counter is
never used with the same key and then
the next is requires careful management
of the counter to maintain security and
with that guys we have come to the end
of this session I hope you found it
useful and informative if you like this
session then please like share and
subscribe and you have any questions you
can comment down in the comment section
below and our experts will be happy to
help you as soon as possible until next
time thank you and stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here